hello everyone now let me ask does  anyone smell toast you're dang right you  do don't worry you're not having a  stroke  well a stroke of good luck maybe because  until now the only way to make toast was  the hard way  Thanks current president well those  awful days are over I am pleased to  introduce to you Milton the toast making  robot TVs Michael Gray Wow you ruined it  oh sorry and hold for applause audience  is still applauding still applauding  still applauding oh I see I have some  fans in the audience and thank you very  much everyone no no really you're you're  too kind  say Michael would you like some toast of  course I like some toast  but toast is a billion-dollar industry  wouldn't I have to pay those outrageous  restaurant prices not anymore thanks to  Milton the toast making robot hey buddy  show them what you can do  normal thanks I've been really blasting  my paw - looks like we've got post